la primera jornada de la cumbre del g7
concluyó con una recepción ofrecida por
la reina isabel como jefa de estado a
todos los líderes participantes de esta
cumbre la primera cara a cara en dos
años estos líderes buscan encontrar la
alternativa para recuperar la economía
mundial tan afectada por esta pandemia
buscan como lo ha llamado el primer
ministro británico a no repetir los
errores del pasado a acabar con las
inequidades del mundo y lograr que
millones de niños en todo el mundo
puedan obtener educación de calidad ha
resaltado boris johnson que por la
pandemia millones de niños no han podido
volver a la escuela también se busca que
haya un compromiso concreto sobre el
acceso a las vacunas de los países en
desarrollo se espera que una de las
iniciativas de las promesas más
importantes de esta cumbre sea la
donación de vacunas para los países en
desarrollo
era la donación de mil millones de dosis
de vacunas contra el hobbit 19 que
aunque es un avance resulta insuficiente
para toda la crisis que está viviendo el
mundo de otro lado hemos visto hoy en la
primera jornada del g7 un cambio de tono
un acercamiento a sus colegas por parte
del presidente de eeuu joe biden quien
ha mostrado un poco más de camaradería
de amistad tratando de recuperar ese
papel tan importante como líder que
tiene eeuu la jornada de este sábado
estará marcada por los participantes
invitados a la cumbre que son australia
india corea del sur y sudáfrica también
este sábado el presidente de francia
emmanuel macrón y el primer ministro
británico boris johnson se reunirán en
la polémica nueva por el break sit está
sobre la mesa y también macro un se
reunirá por el presidente de eeuu joe
baile